hey y'all it's ender couch here in this
tidy tuesday video we're actually not
going to be doing any code
instead i'm actually going to experiment
with this
video format and actually give you some
tips for learning data science
and the first tip that i really have for
you guys is to use your student
discounts
so i know a lot of my viewers are
college students
so you probably have a edu email
or at least an email going through your
university so you should be going to
github education and you'll get
the education pack you just have to give
them your student email
and what's really good about this
education pack
is it comes with a lot of useful tools
so
the main tool i think is the best is
probably the aws
educate um benefit so you get a hundred
dollars of aws
like uh credit and what's really cool
about that is you can actually use
like aws is cloud computing through
redshift so you get 100 100
of essentially cloud computing using
redshift um that means if you have kind
of a crummy laptop like a chromebook or
something like that and you want to do
like
a image neural network you can actually
do it pretty fast
without killing your laptop additionally
you also get github pro
so if you actually look at my github
account um
it'll show you that i have like a pro
account um let's see here
how do i do that yeah it'll say that i'm
pro so there's no
way i would actually buy the pro version
but since i'm a student i get a github
pro account
and actually i'm not really a student um
i just graduated but for some reason i
think
they just give you the um student
they still give you the pro account for
us a year um
another thing that they give you is
let's hear is there there's a data camp
when we look it up
um data camp oops data
camp so they also give you data camp so
you get three months
of a data camp subscription so that's a
good way to learn
new things um additionally
i was actually experiment this
experimenting with this last night and
you can also get a one-year domain so if
you go to
what is it andrew couch dot me
and then dash title tuesday i have kind
of like this
really bare-bones title tuesday um page
and then you could view on github and
then see
my github repo for the title tuesday
projects so
if you have um a project that you want
to kind of
make a website for um you can always use
github.io
but then you can also use the student
pack and get
your own domain such as like dot me or
dot
technology etc okay so
what um you also have um besides github
education you also have a tableau
um subscription so you can actually get
tableau for free while you're a student
i'm not sure how long it will last but
you can use tabwell and not pay for it
you also can use the microsoft suite so
i'm sure a lot of everyone has the
microsoft suite but if you don't
um you can go and ask your university to
get
the microsoft suite and lastly i think
it's important to just
look at your university's it supports so
i go to university iowa so if i do like
software
um and then i say uh was it it
i can kind of look at the available
software for the universe i was students
and just download it
so these are very useful things i
actually got a windows 10
um for a spare computer that i i built
so
um you never know there's always some
free things that you can get
okay so my next tip for learning um or
for getting into data science is it
is just to find textbooks online so
many universities will just offer their
uh textbooks online for free
especially ivy league ones so
um one of the most uh popular textbooks
for i guess machine learning is the
elements of statistical learning and i'm
on
stanford's website and you can actually
just download the pdf for free
so um and there's different editions
additionally
if you kind of just look at
these books um you should be focusing on
more applied stuff because when you look
when you have a textbook that has like
applied in it or like
with r or with python they'll generally
give you like a package to actually do
the hands-on
assignments and learning in your
preferred language
so that's also a little additional tip
when you're reading and finding
textbooks
so my third tip for uh getting into data
science
is also to just read online articles
and to watch videos so obviously i have
my own videos but there's also
khan academy um which does a lot of like
preliminary uh stats so if you
are just getting statistics and
probability you can kind of look at
these videos
and do the exercises additionally
um if you really want to get into like
machine learning and
um other statistics stat quest is
probably the
um gold standard for like good
digestible videos with
where you don't really need a background
in statistics
i would also recommend other r data
scientists so
julia silgi is a data science and she
has a blog
and where she kind of talks about tidy
models she actually is one of the
software engineers i think
developing tidy models she also has a
youtube channel
additionally you should be looking at
david robinson uh what's in your studio
uh david robinson uh he has about me
veron's
explained um so
he has a lot of good videos too and he's
the guy who inspired me to do the entire
tuesday project
and lastly um if you want to get into uh
was it if you want to get into uh
neural networks uh code emporium is a
really good channel too
he he really um explains how different
types of neural networks work
and it's a pretty and he has a really
good channel about that type of stuff
so additionally you should also be
looking on twitter
so what's cool about um the tidyverse or
the r community
is that they have a huge uh
our presence or presence on twitter so
if you just look up hashtag our stats
there's always gonna be talk people
talking about using r
on their own projects so there's always
a lot of cool people to follow
um many people on the r studio team
um are on twitter and they're very
active on twitter you can
also look up tidy tuesday
and you can see people's uh kind of like
how how they looked at the
uh tight tuesday data set and what
charts they made
additionally um if you're looking up
textbooks
you should also be looking at github.io
so these are pr
these are um users from github so topo
or i don't know how to pronounce his
name oops
uh topipo yeah people he
is max [ __ ] who created carrot so he has
a lot of uh
little small websites talking about
um carrot etc so here's him kind of
explaining carrot
all the things that goes into it i mean
i did a video on
interpretable machine learning and this
guy basically kind of put his book onto
a github.io
account or website and you can go
through it
so whenever you're looking at a textbook
um in a programming language
it you should always kind of look up to
see if there's a github.io
page for it okay
and then my fourth uh tip for getting
into data science
is to look at uh lecture slides from
other classes
so most like iv level um colleges or
universities will kind of
offer their actual classes
slides online so you can kind of look at
what people are learning
you can go over the slides um
see here's lecture six on bayesian
estimation you can kind of
read through it um additionally um
warren school of business has their
department of statistics and you can
kind of look at all of their classes
so adapter variable selection credit
modeling etc
um and that's just a good way to learn
stuff so if you want to look
up um a lot of classes that you can't
take
say if you're if you're like a
psychology student and you want to learn
more about
you know computer science and machine
learning um you probably can't take
those classes at your
university without prereqs but you can
look up like
uh what is it um you can just kind of
look up
uh computer science class and i think uh
stanford
has one online
uh was it and just do like youtube
uh so there's there's definitely like uh
program methodology so
cs106a um i think
what's let's see what else does mit has
a lot of classes
on mit courseware so you can learn a lot
um a lot of you basically learned about
anything so
not just about uh computer science
machine learning statistics
so these are always good resources to
kind of look at the more like
formal and more academic way of learning
and then lastly i would just say to
start your own projects
so starting your own projects and just
sharing them with people
so for example like just start up a
github
um create a bunch of repos you don't
have to share all of them but it's
always nice to just kind of work on a
project
kind of get into the actual weeds of it
to figure out what you
what you do know and what you don't know
so a lot of times when you're kind of
copying code
you realize that you were just copying
code and didn't have an actual
understanding of it
so doing your own projects where uh
there's no set
goal or there's no set like way to do it
is a good way to do things
i also would recommend just working
collaboratively so
a good they're always telling people
that you should always have side
projects on your resume
however it's a good way to really meet
and network with other people who are
in your similar position or who are
interested in the same field or things
that you're in
is to work collaboratively on projects
um
and lastly i think um just to go back on
things is just to document
all of your data all of your projects
and also deploy your projects
so it's always nice to have a project
that you can just view online
and one good thing is you can always use
shinyapps.io
if you have a shiny application or
dashboard that you can put in
you also have like public uh was it
public
tableau we can kind of show it to like a
recruiter or a friend or a professor
so those are the main things i'm just
going to emphasize that
one you should always use your student
email to find discounts and free things
just you should also be reading
textbooks that you can always find
online
you should also focus on the apply
things because generally they'll come
with
a package to actually go through the the
textbook for you
the third tip is to basically read
online articles and watch videos and
also check out
the our community on twitter and then my
fourth tip is to always
look for lecture slides from classes
that you
want to take because they generally will
post them online for free
especially these iv level classes and
then finally always start projects
share them with people work
collaboratively and deploy
so i know this is kind of a quick video
but i've been kind of busy so i'll see
you guys next week and tidy on